l'organisation mondiale de la santé de
plus en plus inquiète de la situation en
europe après l'amérique latine et
d'autres régions du monde
l oms met en garde le vieux continent
vis-à-vis de la situation sanitaire lié
aux coronavirus en effet certains pays
ont vu leur nombre de cas repartir
brutalement à la hausse la semaine
dernière notamment en europe centrale
est cette augmentation du nombre de cas
peut s'expliquer par un plus grand
nombre de tests mais également par la
découverte de kloster d'envergure
notamment en allemagne est néanmoins ces
explications n'ont pas de quoi rassurer
le ms las creek la semaine dernière
l'europe a connu une augmentation du
nombre de cas est de madère pour la
première fois depuis des mois rixe
pendant des semaines j'ai évoqué le
risque de résurgence de ce phénomène au
fur et à mesure que les pays adaptent
leurs mesures dans plusieurs pays
d'europe
ce risque est maintenant devenu une
réalité trente pays ont vu augmenter le
nombre de nouveaux cas cumulés au cours
des deux dernières semaines dans 11 de
ces pays
l'accélération de la transmission a
entraîné une résurgence très importante
qui si elle n'est pas maîtrisée poussera
les systèmes de santé au bord du gouffre
une fois de plus en europe de brink wang
europe et on continue de parler la
situation sanitaire en europe et en
france avec le professeur jean postale
infectiologues et professeur de médecine
infectieuses au chu de grenoble alpes
bonjour jean paul stahl merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
avec les éléments les perspectives dont
vous disposez donc devons nous craindre
un fort rebond du cours aux navires us
en europe
c'est certainement une hypothèse qu'il
faut considérer le ce qu'on a toujours
considéré les le relâchement ou les
mesures de les confinements on va dire
accompagné du relâchement on a pu
constater récemment aussi bien en france
que dans d'autres pays européens montre
que le risque existait le virus continue
à circuler
les clusters sont là pour le rappeler
alors pour l'instant ils sont maîtrisés
mais juste à temps donc là il ya
effectivement une vraie attention
apportée ce phénomène nous ne sommes pas
sortis d'une crise d'une crise
épidémique et il faut continuer à faire
attention je ne dis pas qu'il faut re
confiné là tout de suite bien sûr que
non mais il faut continuer à faire
attention
vous parliez à l'instant d'un
relâchement qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu
faire tout simplement de deux différents
dans cet art de déconfinement aurait
déjà la fête de la musique et
l'extraordinaire exemple de ce qu'il va
faire je veux dire des rassemblements de
personnes même si ce ne sont pas
c'étaient les jeunes donc c'est pas les
plus les personnes les plus à risques
mais ils sont ils peuvent transmettre
des personnes plus à risque donc ce
genre de comportement est effectivement
problématique si on regarde en
angleterre les images que j'ai vues sur
les plages anglaise c'est sont tout
aussi problématique avec des gens qui
sont les uns à côté des autres sans
aucune restriction ni où ni aucune
barrière s'est effectivement pas
raisonnable donc là il ya vraiment
quelque chose à garder garder au coin de
la tête
il faut avoir une vigilance même
d'une parce que effectivement le virus
se voit plus haut se voit peu mais ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas des
contaminations rampante et donc il faut
continuer à faire attention
vous parliez de l'exemple anglais et
français est ce que vous pensez que que
les états européens notamment son sont
trop laxistes avec ce genre de
rassemblement mais je les lirai louis
mais je dirais que oui à la fois ils
sont entrés très dur pour certains qui
sont ce que c'est l'impression que cela
c'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression que
certains sont hyper contrôlée et hyper
sollicitées pour pour garder les mesures
draconiennes comme les restaurants par
exemple
et puis de l'autre côté il ya les
rassemblements de foules qui sont
autorisés donc deux poids deux mesures
je crois qu'il faut il faudrait une
unité de comportement
quelle est la situation est exactement
dans votre a chu est ce que l'épidémie
est sous contrôle est ce que vous avez
toujours des malades en réanimation dont
celle où la situation est parfaitement
contrôlée ils l'auront peut dire que le
virus circule de façon extrêmement
faible nous on est dans une ère dans une
région qui a eu la chance d'être
contaminés après les autres finalement
et on a eu le temps de se préparer ça
n'a jamais été une vague qui a submergé
nos capacités d'accueil
donc on est dans une situation très
favorable j'ai pour l'instant c'est
parfaitement maîtrisée chez nous je n'ai
pas le cas partout en france
merci beaucoup jean paul stahl d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues et
professeur de médecine infectieuses au
chu de
grenoble alpes merci beaucoup